los problemas legales se acumulan en
torno al expresidente de Estados Unidos
Donald Trump Y aunque el más reciente ha
sido el más sonado Cuántas causas tiene
pendientes el republicano la última es
la de la actriz de la industria
pornográfica stormi Daniels a finales de
la campaña presidencial de 2016 Trump
habría mandado pagar
130.000 dólares a cambio de su silencio
sobre una aventura que mantuvieron años
atrás y aunque el pago no es ilegal per
se sí lo es si se considera que
favoreció su campaña política pero esta
no es la que más problemas le podría
causar al político conservador el asalto
al Capitolio El Seis de enero de 2021 se
saldó con una causa penal contra Trump
el motivo haber instigado a sorda de
Seguidores a actuar violentamente
acciones por las que el republicano fue
condenado en una investigación política
que recomendó condenarlo por cuatro
delitos
en paralelo a la investigación del
Capitolio el FBI incautó al menos 15
cajas con archivos al clasificados de su
residencia de Mara lago algo que podría
traerle problemas penales ya que según
expertos cualquier retención o
destrucción de documentos de la Casa
Blanca incurre en delito tras estas
polémicas llegó el caso contra su
empresa familiar la Trump organization
señalada por fraude fiscal hurto mayor y
falsificación de registros todo para
evadir impuestos de prebendas a altos
ejecutivos durante 15 años y resultó en
una investigación penal ya resuelta
contra el director financiero y otra
civil que pide 250 millones de dólares a
Trump y tres de sus hijos no obstante el
republicano sostiene que todas estas
causas tienen motivaciones políticas y
ya ha dicho que ninguna de ellas le hará
renunciar a presentarse a la presidencia
en 2024